yes click hello and welcome to our
Monday night live show while everything
is working alright I have the microphone
switched on that's good
let's get going investing started it's
that true
I get Haga in the very first game oh my
goodness and he's not playing B six
maybe seven no I know it goes G 6 he's
preventing me from playing B 3 ok let's
see what is up to C 6 ok yeah so we get
some sort of Kings in here I wasn't
aware that this is part of his
repertoire ok so he gives me the bishop
here for what exactly
not much really
ok so I just have the bishop here and
it's not clear what is compensation is I
can try the click a three before stuff
maybe he goes ninety-seven and f5 but
that doesn't really put any pressure on
me okay
Wow Wow
that is a really slow approach the
question is do I take on something else
what sound 9a for funky dollars what
song I'm not sure
hmm I'm not entirely certain how I
should play here that looks a bit
strange admittedly but
I don't see a clear way to refute it
there should be two looks really strange
now okay so I'm taking us and it takes
enormous amount of time what is doing
but it's still not so easy to break
through
hmm not super satisfied I can play 94
and put more pressure on on the beef on
the c5 pawn and some I mean I've used
two and a half minutes after 14 they
said what in booth and I will see what
is y is going to do so if he had see if
he felt compelled to take so here now c5
is the normal mode I can prepare it
and move like real age six is not
comfortable for me but can I do
something else here
c5 immediately probably is not not so
effective details B takes see if I'll be
five okay I just want to see the movie
happy yeah that's what I expected
now I'm going back
ready form c5 now Queen c7 I will
probably play c5 but he will he is able
to get to the sex okay g5 and Bishop g4
is an additional idea that I can try so
this is making things a little bit more
flexible I am covering c4 and I have
Group H 1 and H 5 as a potential idea I
wanted I wanted to play should be 6 but
this is probably not bad now cannot
easily take you for a time warning
right H 5 2 F 4 is possible here I just
blended that friggin pong it's the way
to lose this game blundering him some
pawns
that was really stupid my black words of
course totally outplayed there but this
is not clear at all
no it's cleared so let's like is better
ok I have blundered away too many pawns
it's not clear though but rupees hell
really threatens you can probably just
push the a pawn also even 90 85 is maybe
a move so this check is the threats
check cannot really invest much time
anyway some have to play quickly check
got 20 seconds it's the main problem the
position might be there but it's maybe
something I can still stand
somehow check check check
yeah it was lucky of course it was lost
near the end but before a black all of
the young all of the pawns that was
pretty terrible I mean this position is
strategically lost to black but I didn't
play it right okay so let's go for the
next game yeah cats sitting on the
keyboard candy - weird chat messages
it's what currently is discussed in the
chat yeah thanks to all the regulars in
the chat but nice to see all of you
there so I've got a new game request out
and hope I get PR again some good guys
currently waiting on the pairing
young now this position is really really
good yeah the engine just plays C 5 and
wins basically yeah probably g4 almost
of a good idea while I wait for a new
game I can have a look there
yes game started now we got a game
against mister my way so what okay I
have a funny him I know that he plays a
funny line here and I recently checked
this line so I know it looks completely
bonkers but yeah this is not not correct
for whites but it is absolutely
absolutely fun to play okay so white has
tons of development but is also central
pawn down
almost you feel tempted to play six
simply to have them have the temple when
I was analyzing this I was thinking I
was analyzing this recently I was
thinking take stakes and c4 I believe he
is he for was my idea I had some idea
okay so my way is thinking after I
blitzed out orders I remember that he
plays that deadline yeah this makes
really make some sense and taking more
is very greedy laughter what how do I
play this Queen d7 runs into further
Tempe Quincy eight gives one pawn back
maybe Queen d6
Queen b3 then maybe our taking looks
really risky this is not for greed its
it what I try as to maybe I wanted to
prevent him from getting to b3 was one
thing yeah why does a pretty good
compensation yeah my way is usually
around this rating it's been higher
below one
okay so b5
I know it's loose but it's also a temple
Queen has to go back that's what I think
okay but Queen d8 is a queen Trajan am I
still getting mated them all
is anything else
[Music]
oh wow I thought you would just trade
now that looks weird
85 I can't believe it
okay so go in here I guess I still have
all my pawns which is pretty funny I
have all my balls left and Bishop takes
before the rather nice tempo so here he
will take one have six play 94 I am okay
so I probably need to do this but I've
already really a ton of pawns up so I
don't need to grab you even warm the
objectively speaking I'm winning but
still has to be done how many pots I
have seven got three extra pawns three
three is good really good
I gave so what is my plan maybe before
when see three simply steamrolling white
not not developing but played before
if I can get in like b4 c3 Knight to g5
I'm just winning at least that's what I
think
interesting
yeah it looks at e6 and c6 but still
don't so don't think at all that
dangerous they should run into Tempe
I should work
I wanted to take which which is kind of
stupid on c3 my okay maybe that is not
tidy stupid hood before yeah now it will
sacrifice on e6 which is objectively not
working probably but it's dangerous
though
and I probably should have played it
differently somehow and yeah Knight
friggin e6 is still me I am check shoot
time morning I am such an idiot I'm
spoiling this game I cannot believe it
it was such a totally winning position
ah
Milan rook d7 I'm an idiot losing this
is super terrible really
yeah I'm giving this record King f8 here
King evaders was roopd 7 couldn't do
that and this is also hanging yeah I'm
really angry here this is this is
terrible there was a complete joke on
the pawn sacrifice over it just did not
look at all ok
check check check check check and check
check check check check check check
black for Fitz on time this is probably
draw I know probably not that come on
this is really making me angry I'm like
five palms up and it's a complete joke
and I'm still supporting this nonsense
this is terrible and probably everything
wins in this in this position I mean I
can also just Castle the whole time it's
really really terrible man just castle
yeah and it's over yeah this is this is
totally winning now okay enough sever
stupid have calling you see that he only
has this is this desperation sacrifice
and it wins of course in the area that's
the only idea left here the only friggin
idea left and everything winter
absolutely everything I mean this is
also totally terrible you can yes to
take and this isn't even so clear yeah
it really is like this this yeah instead
this is just losing effect but it didn't
it didn't lose
okay so I got a new game request out
yeah you lose stuff like that I mean
your opponent just yet I take four pawns
and game started this knockin on blank
on and playing some wacky stuff now
that's the only way to do it against do
this something give me 97 unfortunately
not
okay yeah this is not all that exciting
now I mean I'm okay here with this
position
it was a quite typical thing all the
kings in your attack I've had those
pollutions a lot when I was a kid and
this looks fairly good actually I think
I get in f4 quickly
I mean it's kingside this would be
deserted
yeah whatever can displace your bishop
as well if you like the bishop is
completely misplaced on a6 because
Knight f5 becomes a lot stronger now
and so Quincy fall hmm I can cover this
first
it's not it's not as great as I thought
and a bishop brewery is misplaced with
really what am I not understanding here
that looks really really strange for
black what does he get some counterplay
there that I don't see maybe
what exactly is black doing hand this
game Knight f5 looks good I'm not
threatening 96 unfortunately as the
Queen can take yep but how to go from
here just rupee one maybe and queen g-46
cute retina key six and I'm running into
a self freaking pin that can happen if
you don't take take the game series
anymore can't okay yeah so I set the
piece just I have to do something
Queen h4 is also big an idea takes tanks
let's try this
we should be four at what point not sure
which move
yeah anyway why does that work
radon age 7
Masum protein is making a tech now
don't see a move black resigns yeah it
was not not very correct as a tech but I
think around here I must I must have a
fantastic position I mean there must be
good for white and probably just go back
and win in the attack and by taking with
everything that must be good forward
okay let's go for the next game
yeah Willie Gus this request I kind of
understand they're always kind of their
tents let's say those games but I don't
think he's on don't seem in the list of
title players so let's see who I'm going
to get request is out
yeah there's a some discussion in the
chat about some old game I hit against
all I guess I mean my score still [ __ ]
against him but game started oh there's
a new game and playing Bret yeah okay
pick one bankroll /bin only I can play
possession oh my god
preventing quinta between preventing
Bishop f4 yeah this is a funny funny
line now where I think like it's taking
slight liberties in getting of with
getting a somewhat more interesting
position but it's a bit risky oh my god
is just straight everything yeah my
score against we gots got 33 percent but
this is not great I understand but and
it was a far lower score yeah really I
have how many wins total I got eight
wins against 26 losses which is not good
yeah I'm completely yeah I agree
if you say is terrible but I've had a
worse score my god this is not very
exciting oh my god interest rates
everything this guy like absolutely
everything yeah so it's actually it's
actually not that bad form White has
this f4 f5 idea I'm not sure how
dangerous it is with the double G pawn
it plays it like instantly of course em
yeah g6 I'm not sure if I like this
you
takes with the Queen
he stood at xt5
hmm slightly somewhat annoying really
but still don't seem and much danger
that set off my problem I don't see much
danger in most game in most depositions
got really good at identifying opponents
resources okay I will be seven is the
idea
now that sucks it really does not look
good
rookies have another problem
just to get 3G 3m or this
hope g3 and it's extremely annoying
now go g6 but it really doesn't look
good
yeaji success just just Queen f6 I guess
Auto gauge 3
I have absolutely no counterplay
Queen f6 27 so Luke age 3 is probably
stronger which you will find plays it
fantastically well of course time
warning yeah promise at both they'll
threaten both h6 and Queen f6 g6 bottom
VI when you move ahead f6 it wasn't good
but it was something to consider because
this is losing yeah they're just killed
me lack very nice you just killed me I
played that really badly I mean I don't
think I should use this but somehow I
did maybe I have to play at 6 and to
stop the gee-pole I probably have to do
this it looks a little weird but I
probably have to stop the Jeep on here
this is probably a premier one game
started Wow who the heck is that
look at that Fight Club 3 to 6 whatever
Russia GM's okay so I have to beat this
to 6 guy get my points back ok he knows
his moves
okay so how do you do how to play this I
know I just try to play simple
[Music]
we're 265 in the five-minute - I didn't
one-night h5f for to happen this is why
I took this
and stop such a bad position I like this
I am yeah I have a + Co against the sky
he wants to go 96 to f4
yeah but isn't this kind of K I mean I'm
I'm quite active here you should see six
maybe is that the thing but
it looks very solid okay so how
interesting
so fatigue is six Queen takes Queen to
seven
this is hanging this this maybe it's
it's good on d5 anyway yeah it's a chick
c7 now
taking physics is stupid okay Queen
takes Knight takes pawn takes which it
takes it's probably not great yes okay
so probably that wasn't such a great
idea to put the bishop on 25
I probably still have to do this don't
really see anything else and now yeah
my tEEX doesn't work this is what's my
idea
[Music]
maybe Queenie six is good I start
freezing
I can maybe take a 93 I think he has got
26 yes
9595 book takes takes then okay so I
have to move the night-night if Y goes
to e7 ABC 45
I've got to hear too many bishops is the
problem too many bishops yeah it wasn't
that was the issue with this whole line
that's true I cannot move the night time
morning mm-hmm yeah I'd like behind I
felt like this was kind of a careful
wine-off
today I didn't see this wrong I felt I
might have some chances but now is this
it to them to the game and it's too bad
that's really just too bad okay mmm
let's go for the game sorry my voice is
failing me
yeah that's really good movie night
the night is wrongly placed there and he
gets a TM once you see it it's obvious
but still you have to do it
yeah maybe before when hind side isn't
great they should just play like
normally they are c4 instead of 26 maybe
yeah I can take care of that what's the
problem
something like that looks pretty awful I
have a new game request out but don't
get paired
we're wasting fighting the computer
actually thinks that this is okay for me
game style
okay new game against the wrists so
whatever is it and we get another coins
maybe five nz6
this is a tricky line which is not
really nice to play in blitz with like I
have to really say
now probably six I can also do this by
the way it looks really weird
so he prevents Bishop f5 maybe I can
prepare but should I fight so we have
somebody creativity Alice's what else
what I really like about the click on so
sometimes get reasonably fresh positions
early on something that you have never
really considered so c3 yeah maybe I ta
get to make it a little bit more dynamic
before he gets in c3 and we have the C
file symmetrical and so on this is now
um some sort of French position it
should be kind of okay you know I have
to say that I don't know those positions
all that well never scored a lot in the
French this is maybe a move Knight to e4
little bit unusual comes with the temple
maybe Quincy to simply well LT isn't
Queen a five a movie and tween 85 know
when it takes be seven I can do this
though 93 as a threat after Knight takes
pawn takes Queen takes yeah in the chat
h6 is mentioned that's not a very
typical move in those positions
let's true it makes f6 a lot more
difficult to play so it gives the
exchange however however is that they
look to be eight threatening would be
six how is he saving his queen let's see
light III was winning material already
but it would be six um traps the Queen
it is no squares
maybe has to tribe yeah give that that's
giving some material there for the Queen
rupee six Queen takes e5 that's actually
quite a good try
in practical terms I mean I should win
but still he's hanging on but it is band
c3 is so weak HOA week I should be able
to win that Quincy five
it's got ninety four
yeah this is good yeah rook takes a - I
guess Nexus snatch this material yeah
how do I get to the F to pawn and get
him let's get out of the check
just a six probably be 696 yeah I can
push this pong also should be fine yeah
the only thing is I shouldn't like fall
into some stupid mating net covering it
I tend to screw up screw screw up those
things with some really really weird
ideas okay let's just push this now
[Music]
this isn't really a threat I think which
is heaven or something if you move the
book
time warning look III g3
look t3i can play Queen takes c6
the ape on wings and down to 30 seconds
I didn't really recognize that
new palm is just promoting ready
check check check check
quite resigned okay so I got a win in
here
yeah maybe a quick game to finish things
off see if I can get a quick game going
anybody funny on no not really
yeah one more game would be fine
see see if I can get one yeah it was a
fun Ian there's one instructive moment
and like en 93 years we could back game
started how long how long what holla we
do ha ha ha whoo ha
so we've got a and Kings Indian Trojan
if I never get this right
what is that cool paint or something UAE
no Jordan okay
early Queen 3/8
have a plate this guy deformed possibly
this kind of attack should not work
normally
but in blitz games yeah we know and
anything can happen so how to how to do
this c5 immediately is possible Queen b3
I can also do this G form there I'm
playing h3 first
which is six
[Music]
yeah it's got [ __ ] g6 and g4l I mean you
just doesn't care at all about anything
you just place the stuffing
let's go to turn green g6 next yeah it's
not only I like to play
I suppose like you might just take no
six I can go to age three now think want
to cut this off first Queen age three
was always possible and again scream g6
I think
create three Queen f3 queen h3 there's
there is a king of seven remaining
macking a son why am I playing this is
if I know that destiny was coming
yeah I'm losing this freaking game which
is move shame normally this does not
work what like history but it I couldn't
refute it I just couldn't refute it yeah
nice just nice white very high I have to
have to look at this briefly because
this is supposed to be simply unplayable
for black - this stuff is unplayable
if white should win on the Queen side
and there's nothing on the Kings side
somehow I applied the defense
I played the defense badly here you
cannot play f4 g5 and the controls and
usually because the attack is too slow
probably clean b3 was bad this is what I
did here this is probably too ambitious
I mean I'm winning on the Queen side
already so I probably have to play more
defensively
I have to create more defensively
something like that maybe like on g4
play Bishop H form these kind of things
probably something like that is madam
it's still tough it's always tough to
analyze the engine gives wipe almost a
wheel in this position it's just like
the different help really doesn't but
probably something like that where I'm
just defending defending this Queen d3
is probably I'm dislocating the Queen to
much like this
this is very good for white I have to do
it like that yeah queen bee 3 is bad
well as interesting a queen bee 3 I
wanted to force through a 5 fun even
more effectively but it just it just
blew up in my face ok guys thanks for
watching it was an interesting final
game there I'll be back next week bye
bye